le monde est entré en guerre contre un
adversaire invisible face à la pandémie
de covile 19 les moyens déployés sont
radicaux et parfois désespérés aux
grands maux les grands remèdes
seulement voilà le remède il n'en existe
encore aucun contre le nouveau
coronavirus pour y remédier les
scientifiques sont en première ligne
nous avons suivi trois équipes qui sont
entrés dans la course aux médicaments et
aux vaccins contre la maladie
celle de gary cowger directeur du centre
de recherche en infectiologie du chul
québec de son collègue l'infectiologue
guy boivin et du microbiologiste der au
hasard à nous verser de la saskatchewan
c'est vraiment tout le monde sur le pont
on travaille sans arrêt autant qu'on
peut lui aussi vite qu'on plus la tâche
est immense il faut décoder le virus
comprendre son fonctionnement
dans quel tissu il se reproduit les
terminer quels animaux de laboratoire il
peut infecter tout ça dans l'espoir de
contrer garric ablinger n'en est pas à
sa première crise sanitaire
il a contribué à mettre au point un
traitement et un vaccin contre la
maladie et vola il a travaillé sur le
gic à la grée pachen l'urgence il
connaît ou cdd moment important c'est
que c'est sûr qu'il ya une once à
l'énergie puis évidemment faire tout ce
qu'on peut le plus rapidement possible
dès les débuts l'épidémie son équipe
s'est lancé à la recherche d'un vaccin
coronavirus c'est du matériel génétique
entouré d'une enveloppe surmonter deux
protéines qui forment comme une couronne
d'où son nom de corona pour qu'un vaccin
fonctionne il faut qu'il apprenne à
notre système immunitaire à reconnaître
ce virus pour mieux le détruire
pour y arriver on peut utiliser le virus
entier ou encore une ou plusieurs de ces
partis
gary comme une guerre planche sur quatre
méthodes différentes à la fois
pour qu'on puisse en bout de ligne avoir
le plus possible de données sur le plus
possible de stratégie puis choisir à
travers ça le plus vite possible
quelques candidats qui vont pouvoir
avancer plus rapidement vers une
application clinique
oui on en a des vaccins et des
traitements qu'on peut on peut générer
en quelques semaines
mais est-ce qu'on peut les amener
jusqu'au gens jusqu'à sauver des vies en
quelques semaines ou en quelques mois
c'est ça la grosse question développer
un vaccin
ça prend du temps il faut créer le
produit mais aussi le tester en
plusieurs étapes sur des animaux d'abord
puis sur des humains pour s'assurer
qu'il n'est pas dangereux et qu'il est
efficace
puis il faut le produire en quantité
suffisante et enfin l'administré aux
populations vulnérables à saskatoon
lynch nash nos racines center a pour
vocation de développer des vaccins
contre les maladies émergentes dans l'un
de ces sept laboratoire dédié à l'étude
des pathogènes dangereux des rafales
zaranou et son équipe font croître le
virus qui servira à tester l'efficacité
de leur vaccin expérimental leurs
produits visent une protéine à la
surface du virus
appelée protéine spike c'est la clé qui
permet au virus d'entrer dans les
cellules pour les infectés
[Musique]
c'est la preuve qu'à peu près tout le
monde privilégie mais il ya plusieurs
façon de s'y prendre
et tant mieux si les différents groupes
s'y mettre parce qu'on ne sait pas
vraiment à quoi devrait ressembler un
vaccin contre le coronavirus il n'en
existe aucun jusqu'à il ya quelques
semaines les chercheurs travaillaient
sur un autre coronavirus celui du
syndrome respiratoire du moyen-orient
depuis 2012 ce virus transmis par les
dromadaires a tué plus de 800 personnes
surtout dans la péninsule arabique
or on n'a toujours pas de vaccin pour le
contrer ça fait cinq ans qu'on travaille
sur un vaccin contre le recours aux
navires une moyenne rire n'est pas
encore très utilisée accélérant les
choses on parle d'un minimum d'un an ou
un an et demi pour un vaccin contre le
nouveau coronavirus et je ne vois pas
comment on pourrait faire un retour à
québec où l'équipe du dr guy boivin fait
le point ici en attendant un vaccin on
espère identifier des médicaments qui
pourrait soigner la malaise
les anti héros qu'on a développée par
exemple contre la grippe le tamiflu dont
on entend souvent parler c'est une
protéine du virus de la grippe très
spécifiques
alors petits pas présenté ses serments
suite corneau virus donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut développer des cordes et et
rythmes actions spécifiques à chacune
des espèces de vivre heureux hasard un
tout nouveau laboratoire de confinement
a été inaugurée en pleine crise du
coronavirus il était destiné à l'étude
du dangereux virus de la grippe aviaire
les chercheurs ont changé de cible nous
on fait ce qu'on appelle du
repositionnement thérapeutique
alors c'est quoi le repositionnement
thérapeutique c'est de prendre un
médicament qui est une indication à
kenny x et trouver une nouvelle
indication il direct n'est pas née
d'abord connu jusqu'à maintenant il faut
savoir que cette approche nous permet
des d'âge est beaucoup plus rapidement
de développer beaucoup plus rapidement
enchaîné ailleurs des dizaines d'essais
cliniques ont déjà commencé pour tester
des traitements contre la corvette 19
de nombreux gouvernements et
institutions ont débloqué des fonds
d'urgence pour appuyer ses recherches
pour les scientifiques c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais ils sont unanimes c'est un
combat qu'il faudra mener sur le long
terme ce qui se fait aujourd'hui en
vaccinologie compte ce qu'auront à
vireux cela est très important pour le
futur parce que il faudra pas arrêtée
l'année prochaine ou dans six mois ou
dans deux mois on espère tous qu'il va
arrêter mais il faut continuer pour
qu'on avance pour que la prochaine fois
mais on soit prêt on commence à
comprendre que c'est l'équipe virus qui
vont sauter la barrière nous
on ne travaille plus ou moins rapproché
il faut être prêt il faut être très
avancé
il commence
le sprint qui a commencé devra sans
doute se transformer en marathon